optimal at this altitude I can run flat
out for a half mile before my hands
start shaking so nicely for some
question now I'm a cybernetic organism
living tissue over metal endoskeleton so
this episode is brought to you by Inc
tel and I've used them personally ever
since I wrote the 4-hour workweek
I've been asked over and over again how
I choose to delegate tasks how I do
80/20 analysis and so on at the root of
many of those decisions is a simple
question actually two questions number
one how can I invest money to improve my
quality of life I use that an investing
as well
the second how can I spend a little
money or moderate money to save
significant time Intel is one of those
investments they're a turnkey solution
for all of your imaginable customer care
needs
I used Intel during the launch of the
4-hour body which was very very involved
and they provided 24/7 customer service
for my landrush campaign because it was
critical for me to take care of every
person who purchased my books and
participated this allowed me to focus on
the things that I am better at my
strengths like the marketing plan that
we'd worked on for six months
implementing that Intel trains their
experience customer service reps to know
your business and your products inside
and out and make your customers raving
fans they answer more than a million
customer service requests every year and
they can do so across all platforms
including email phone social media text
even chat leaving your customers with
poor service or just mediocre service
which by the way in a competitive pool
is a huge liability long wait times or
unanswered messages carries a massive
cost and risk to your business Intel
removes the logistics and headaches of
this type of communication allowing you
to focus on your strengths and grow your
business it can be a real competitive
advantage and I see many many e-commerce
companies and tech companies thinking of
customer service as a good enough check
or an afterthought and just like Airbnb
is design in innovative ways to be a
competitor and to win you can do the
same thing with customer service so as a
listener of this podcast you can get up
to ten thousand dollars off that's a big
discount ten thousand dollars off your
startup fees and costs by visiting Inca
Telecom forward slash Tim so check it
out
for more info go to Inca telecom i NK te
l comm forward slash Tim this episode is
brought to you by Legal Zoom I have used
Legal Zoom myself for many of my
businesses and many of the icons on this
podcast have actually used Legal Zoom
for instance Matt Mullenweg of WordPress
Fame CEO of automatic which is now worth
more than a billion dollars first
incorporated his company on Legal Zoom
Legal Zoom is a reliable resource that
more than a million people have already
trusted to help with their businesses
whether that's setting up a will doing a
proper trademark search forming an LLC
setting up a non-profit or finding
simple cease and desist letter templates
man do I use a lot of those LegalZoom is
not a law firm but they do have a
network of independent attorneys
available in most states they can give
you advice on the best way to get
started provide contract reviews and
otherwise help you run your business and
important there are no surprises Legal
Zoom provides complete transparency that
means upfront pricing customer reviews
and a satisfaction guarantee
check out legalzoom.com today to see how
they can make life better and easier for
you in your business if you're
pretending to be a lawyer on the
internet then you are asking for trouble
put together the safety nets get your
t's crossed and your eyes dotted
enter promo code tim t IM at
legalzoom.com to save 15% that's t IM
for 15% off check it out legalzoom.com
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show or is my job to
deconstruct world-class performers of
all different types from the worlds of
business military entertainment
athletics and sometimes combinations of
different fields and that is the case
with this interview of course the
objective is to tease out tactics
routines habits specifics that you can
use and my guest this time around is by
popular request jason khalipa that's kha
Li pa you can say hello at jason khalipa
on instagram twitter etc he is one of
the fittest men in the world a title
that was officially his when he earned
it at the CrossFit Games and won the
CrossFit Games in 2008 he is an eighth
time CrossFit Games competitor a
three-time Team USA CrossFit member and
among other athletic feats he is dead
lifted 550 pounds squatted 450 pounds
and performed 64 pull-ups at a body
weight of 210 pounds this podcast very
important note of course you are most
likely listening to this as audio only
we have a bunch of video bonuses and
tutorials from Jason recorded in my home
gym and elsewhere which you can find at
youtube-dot-com forward-slash
Tim Ferriss two hours and two S's
keeping in mind that beyond sports
Jason is also a very successful
entrepreneur he is the founder and CEO
of NC Fit which has more than 20
locations in 8 different cities and he
is the co-founder of box to business
which is a nonprofit that helps gyms
become profitable businesses Jason uses
the proceeds from box to business to
help fight pediatric cancer we cover a
ton of stuff in this episode a lot of
specifics a lot of stories including his
training and diet the hardest workouts
he's ever performed the mentor who
taught him how to sell anything which is
hilarious how he and his family have
coped with his daughter's battle with
cancer how he has navigated going from
competitive athlete to very very
successful business owner and
much much more so I hope you enjoyed
this episode as much as I did Jason is a
great guy and he is very very generous
with sharing and knowledge and don't
forget to check out the tutorial videos
his favorite warm-ups etc at
youtube-dot-com forward-slash tim
ferriss Jase will do a quick sound check
you please tell me what you had for
breakfast I had kale smoothie and an egg
with bacon on top one egg with bacon on
top
one egg whole egg no cuz I was on the
road at 4 a.m. I went to Starbucks and I
took the sandwich I took it apart and I
just had the egg with the bacon on top
nice and then the kale smoothie was
before you left the house kale smoothie
was at the gym before IKEA well shortly
after what is in the kale smoothie
besides kale kale peanut butter
sometimes projects like protein powder I
like and almond milk fantastic well I
think we're just going to keep rolling
since that sound check was so successful
and while my pooch Molly is going to
make a racket throwing around an elk
antler we're just going to get to it so
welcome to the show and welcome to I
look my living room I should yeah it's
great to be here and we just had some
fun demoing things and certainly
learning things I wasn't demoing
anything I was observing in the gym in
the garage so for people who are
listening and want some additional video
which I highly highly encourage just go
to Tim blog forward slash podcast and
click on this episode or you can go to
youtube compares two hours two S's and
you can find a bunch of video now you
are considered I know you're not going
to say this but a demigod within the
world of CrossFit by a lot of people
people look up to you for good reason
and I'm curious to know if you were to
look back at your peak competitive
success what do you think the advantages
were that you had or developed like why
were you as successful as you were and
of course you have incredible work ethic
and so on but if you had to sort of dig
into that what do you think the the
elements were that made you and
successful as you were I think primarily
is that I really enjoyed training
I didn't do it you know a lot of people
they like to compete I didn't
necessarily like to compete or or did
like to be I enjoyed competing but I
enjoyed training more I like being an
environment that just pushed me I liked
I liked them getting comfortable
uncomfortable I like leaving the gym and
feel like I just got my butt kicks it
made me feel really good about what I
accomplished and then I went on and
tried to accomplish that same concept
and the rest of my life right and I
think that was something I really picked
up on early on when I first found
CrossFit back in 2006 and then I won the
CrossFit Games in a way and I was able
to compete eight more times mainly
because I just love to Train
you know and the byproduct or the
expression that was my ability to go out
there and compete are there any
particular workouts that come to mind or
exercises anything that you find
particularly enjoyable even though they
might be very painful I mean I like the
ones that give you the biggest return
right I mean I think if you're doing
thrusters yes they're very challenging
they give you a huge return in terms of
benefit in terms of the way you look in
terms where you feel the by practice
strains I think thrusters burpees or
such things if I had to pick several
items I would only do or several
movements I'm going to do for the rest
of my life at these things like that if
we were to say look well we're going to
look forward in a second I want to keep
focusing on that for a moment
any particular if you want to gauge say
the fitness right they cross fitness of
anyone for that matter there any
particular tests that you would put them
through to evaluate that whether it's
like a certain variation of Fran or
anything like that I would just look at
like different metrics and look at you
know what is your mile time how many
Poles q complete what is your max
deadlift back squat press and then start
looking at a few like the movements that
combine both right inside things
sometimes there's people I really get a
running and there's some people are
really good at listening I think the
beauty is when he can combine those two
and so you know a lot of like the Fran's
and the the different types of workout
like a fight gone bad score those are
good ways what is a fight going bad so
fight combat was originally created with
BJ Penn and Greg Glassman a long time
ago and basically was it was back when
BJ was probably training at the health
see cadmium Mountain Dew old-school
right a long time ago and essentially
what it is is one minute one minute one
minute five five movements and then you
one minute rest and you have for three
rounds what are the five movements so
it's a humid old tide pool there's a
push press there's a rower a wall ball
and a box jump and all the movements are
lighted up that you can keep moving on
them and so you know when bj8 finished
as the story goes and BJ finish it was
like oh man that's like a site gone bad
and so that's kind of how the story goes
just as a random side note I used to go
to these chiropractor's the Jansen's who
worked on a lot of fighters and I
remember they described BJ Penn's hip
flexors as the hip flexors of a camel
they said they were just like a
quadricep than normal humans who did a
lot say if you were to say want to get
someone hooked on exercising because you
enjoyed the training not everyone enjoys
training so let's say you're taking
someone you want to get them hooked on
that drug of training is there any
particular approach that you take I mean
you've coached a lot of people you've
I'm sure encountered every different
type of person from NFL player to say
engineer who's never played sports and
everybody in between what do you do to
get someone hooked so that they continue
to come to the gym yes I mean I've been
really fortunate you know over the years
I started company and see fit we have a
ton of members and I've been able to
look at it and say hey what is generally
gets them to kind of stay with us and
more times than not it's starting up
slow and then working their way up I
think a lot of people get gung-ho right
they come in oh you know I want to lose
weight I want to do this one to that
I'll eat whatever you tell me I'll do it
every time and then all this a month
later they're gone right excited the
secret to success is hey just take your
time right this is not a this is this is
a lifelong journey right it's not like a
one-month
you know sad it's you know I want to be
fit I want to be fit for the rest of my
life and so I think it's important to
recognize that and to make small steps
towards right direction you know take
out sugar do this do that small little
steps then go into the gym and start
doing certain stuff but I think finding
a camaraderie finding a coach and find a
community to support you our rule number
one I think that doing it on your own is
very challenging you know you and I were
talking about cooking earlier and it's
like if I want to learn how to cook
really learn how to cook I could learn
from a book I could learn from maybe
watching a show but to really kind of
dive into the nuances I would need to
have someone to kind of show me in the
kitchen what I would do next at least
for me right I don't have enough
experience with it some people go to the
gym sure they can read books you do
stuff but I think having someone Erika
coach advise them on different things is
going to be an easy way trying to get
more success from them yeah I think the
just to reiterate that I think the
social accountability piece is huge
having some type of social cohesion just
gigantic and for people who are
listening it might be in the sticks
don't think you have access to that you
can certainly find communities online
like coach taught me and other other
other sites or services along those
lines but the the point you made also
that I think is really important
underscore is in the beginning focusing
on the good program that you will follow
versus the perfect program that you'll
fit yeah that you'll quit because a lot
of people come in like you said okay I
haven't done anything since college now
I'm going to do a two hour workout five
times a week as my new year's resolution
and they just flame out or they get
injured or fill in the blank and like
said they're gone a few weeks later as
opposed to saying look since you're
starting from zero let's just to
whatever might be a half hour workout
twice a week so that you develop the
habit and then you can always make it
harder or more complex later but if you
make it too hard too complex in the
beginning you're going to be gone yeah
like we have a program that we've
incorporated called The Rise program and
what it incorporates the nutrition is a
mindset coach and I in a fitness coach
and for a lot of people it's all a
mindset right Saul for decades they have
an exercise they've used food as an
outlet or whatever it may be right
that's okay but they need to get over
that in their head to truly make an
impact on and change for for a long time
right instead is making it like this
short term I mean you really get down to
the root of the problem and make it as
more of a part of their daily routine
instead it is something they do right
and that source but to start it slowly
and then work it up is much easier than
just to kind of go crazy and then it
just I haven't seen it work as well and
then right I have a nuclear meltdown at
the restart
and for your next New Year's resolution
that's right
I'm going to take a couple of questions
here that have been volleyed over via
the internet because there are some
really good ones and they range from
training to family to business so we're
going to get to that in a second but I
wanted to ask you you mentioned NC fit
how many locations do you currently have
24 24 locations yeah so you've been very
successful as an athlete and many people
who put in the effort focus that you did
in athletics are so singularly focused
that they have trouble and I've observed
this and friends transferring them to a
career outside of competitor when
sponsored athlete if you were sitting
down with an accomplished athlete or not
who wanted to say get into business and
let's just for the sake of simplicity
say it's similar business they're
somewhere in the Midwest and they want
to get into fitness and gems and so on
what advice would you give them or
resources would you point them to to
increase the likelihood of success yeah
I mean one of the things I'd ask them
and I get asked this often is you know
hey I want to open the gym what do you
think I'm like okay well let's start
with these three simple questions right
number one are you qualified to do so
right what makes you qualified to open
up this business do you have an
expertise in it do you how are you going
to basically give yourself this
competitive advantage that you know that
when you go to open up you're going to
win right where's your competitive
what's the credibility right just
because you like to work out doesn't
mean you should necessarily go open up a
gym where I love to eat I love food but
I sure so I'm not going to open up a
restaurant cuz I'm not qualified to do
so I don't have the training expertise
right and it's okay if you don't in
certain areas just go find an expert in
those other areas right the other thing
I'd ask of you is you know are you doing
it with a strong intention and strong
why right like what is your why why do
you want to open this business is it to
make money because if it's just to make
money
just like competing across the games you
have a strong internal why because when
your backs up against the wall and it's
very challenging you revert back to that
wall
I to push through and in business it's
not always you know rainbows and
unicorns right
there's challenging times and so you
need to be able to revert back to your
internal why of why you started to be
able to do well so I would say a how you
gonna win right tell me how you're going
to win why are you better than the other
guy down the street to do you have a
strong reason why you want to open it
and then three is it a good time in your
life to do it right is it a good time
for you to open it do you just have a
baby do you have a tons of mortgages and
different types of stuff right or is it
a good time in your life to go ahead and
you know go open up this business is
really what I like to ask people what
are the most common mistakes that you
see or that you think you avoided like
if you look back to your business
another way to phrase it so you can
tackle it however you want is what were
some of the most important decisions
that you made looking back I think
looking back it was understanding that
back in the day you weren't going to
make money off your competitive Fitness
career and so I had to open up a
business and I had to open it and I
think one of the best things I ever did
was I recognized a try and Robin steel
as much as I can knowledge from people
around me so when I was in high school I
worked at the front desk at a
conventional gym then when I graduated
high school I went to college I started
working as a sales associate there and I
started making good money so as I'm
going to a junior college I went to West
Valley actually I was there and I just
got woken up like no one cares about me
I was like the jock and I was like the
you know kinda like the class clown in
high school don't forget that college
it's like they don't care about you
right so I really turned the corner I
said hey look you know I need to take
responsibility for what I did get done I
want to be successful and so I started
going to school full-time working
full-time what I also did was I learned
how to talk to people I learned how to
sell which was really important because
in my line of work in the fitness
industry your coach Mir you're talking
people you're coaching em but if you're
a business something else when you learn
how to sell but one of the things I
would also do is on the you know that
twice a week I would go and ride the
elliptical with the owner of the
business
and I would just pick his brain
understand what's going on I think one
of those things early on was recognize
now I want to learn everything I could
from his mistakes so I didn't make as
many
and one of the things we've done a lot
is delegate out things right not you
know have enough of a humbleness to be
like hey look I can't do everything best
if the best I need to hire outside
people and I think I learned that early
on from him learning from him some his
mistakes how did you convince him to do
the elliptical with you what was the
pitch right you're in sales so how did
you get the owner to hang out with the
former class clown on the elliptical so
funny enough he really took me on as
like a mentor he really did like he
really mentored me really well and he
would ride the elliptical as part of his
fitness routine and I would just go over
there and did just go meet with him and
I don't think he disliked it because we
would just you know bullsháá have a good
conversation I think kind of made the
time go by a little bit quicker got it
so you just roll up when he was working
out how to roll and when your back is
against the wall you mentioned the Y so
when you were competing and say this is
actually a question that came up at
least once from people who are listening
to the podcast one want me to ask you
what why did you go back to when you're
competing in the games I mean at the
time right or or I'm sorry to keep
refacing my questions but I've had too
much caffeine and that is when you were
say behind or you saw someone gaining on
you the Y or like what is the self-talk
to make sure that you don't fall out of
but that you don't drop the ball or
otherwise just get get psych down one
thing positive self-talk is a really
hard thing to learn but it's an
important trait to develop and I've
learned that over the years with the
mindset coach I work with where you try
and find ways to reframe things in your
head if something's going wrong instead
of saying oh my legs hurt you say hey
focus on mid-foot strike if you're
running or whatever right you try and
rephrase in a positive and reverting
back to your why I think it's really
important that going into these games
what I would do is I would tell myself
that I've made a commitment to myself my
family to to go out there and do this
and I want to do it because I want to
get comfortable it's uncomfortable I
wanted to see where I stacked up against
my competitors and I want to do it for
me
right and at the time I didn't have as
many other obligations now as life
changes right things change but at the
time my why was he I made a commitment
I'm gonna do
I remember one year we just camp
Pendelton race and I was 210 mile just
crazy hill around and I was like halfway
done I just yeah I'm like going through
like the desert and I look around
there's no one around I'm just like oh
gosh and I feel tarantula it's the true
story I just blocked across from his
look now I'm like what the hell or a big
eyes spider maybe it was in traditional
is big eyes is like what am i doing out
here right and I had to instantly revert
back in my head you know what I made a
commitment that commitment was I was
going to finish out these games so I
better slap myself in the face stop
being a wimp
and finish it because if I allowed
myself to give in then what other things
would I allow myself to give it into my
I made a commitment to myself and I want
to live up to that now over the years
because of other things happening my
life I haven't been able to make that
strong of commitment so therefore I
choose not even to go out there in an
attempt and be I'm very fascinated by
these little moments or days or weeks
that can really affect the complete
trajectory of people's lives and you
mentioned a couple of minutes ago you
get to college age you realize alright
no longer the classic on high school and
you did a course correct right you
started going to school full-time
so what triggered that was it a
particular conversation was it a
particular afternoon yeah what was it so
you know so going out of high school I
thought I was in play football and I'm
not working out so I ended up going to
West Valley and you know first day it
wasn't that big of a deal right I get it
I get to the first day I'm like I'm at
West Valley no big deal I'll transfer
another school in a couple years but all
my friends I gone on for years Santa
clay anniversary which where I ended up
graduating from right but I just
remember first day of school we're going
around we're all saying our names right
it's like hey I'm John this is my first
second year hey I'm Mary this is my you
know whatever second semester whatever
it is and then all of a sudden you have
this woman next to me and I kid you not
right my first class on my first day at
West Valley and Lady goes hi my name is
a Suzanne I can't remember the name
exactly she was but for a fact this is
my seventh year at West Valley and I
just remember looking at her and looking
at this teacher and just be like dude I
gotta get my ass in check and you get my
[ __ ] together right that's I told myself
right
so that moment I left there I went to
the counselor's office and said hey look
I need to figure out the fastest way to
get the heck out of this school and so I
ended up taking full class clothes do
whatever I had to do I end up applying
to Santa Clara two times after that and
not being accepted because I tried after
one year I didn't get accept that tribe
like a year and a half at Inc accepted
then after two years I was accepted
which got me on track to graduating for
so I graduated with all my peers which
was great I graduated my wife actually
which was really cool but that was the
moment that really like kind of sparked
it like dude like playtime's over high
school is done it's you're in the real
world no one really cares about you you
better get your ass in check and when
you applied making me think of Rudy a
little bit so you get applied didn't get
an apply didn't get in then applied and
got in what did you change in between
the not getting accepted and getting
accepted well I had more courses under
my belt sweat okay they didn't have to
use my high school GPA anymore right
you're able to only they call they could
use your Trent your credits it would
transfer that's right got it alright so
so many questions that I'm going to pull
some in from the audiences from fern
Hernandez what are your thoughts on the
frequency of doing Crossfit that's
another way what benefits do you lose or
gain from doing say twice a week versus
four to five times a week I mean I think
by design when you look at like a
program and if it's constantly varied by
design you should be able to do it you
know five days a week and you should be
okay if the programming isn't
appropriate and the volume is good and
you're listening to your body you should
feel to perform that program you know
five days a week because of the variance
right you should be able to go long one
day heavy one day you know a little
parallel one day and that just depends
on how much effort people put into the
program itself so two days is better
than no days but two days is also
challenging if you go in you get really
sore and then you're recover and you're
really sore again hey your body never
gets into this rhythm so assuming you go
to a gym that is good programming I
think you can go you know five days a
week and you know we're also though just
to touch on good programming in the gym
when we're messing around messing around
you're demonstrating backs while we're
talking about five by five and so on
these five five sets of five reps and so
on if the variance doesn't exist and
some
trying to do 5x5 seven times a week with
give a pep squad yeah I mean you got a
yachtie of a program has variants rights
the way we do it at our GM is we have
one person creates this template the
skeleton then he creates the workouts
and we have a peer reviewed by six other
of our coaches and then it gets back to
him so we try to have a lot of checks
and balances on program because
regardless of who is programming the
program there's always going to be some
type of bias towards what you like sure
and always and so you need to have other
people have checks and balances on that
how might someone create a skeleton of a
program and I'm not saying just Joe Blow
in the street I'm saying one of your
coaches right what what does that
process look like what are they thinking
about or considering as they do it well
might think they're looking at time
domains right so you're looking at you
know are we talking in five minutes we
talk in twelve minutes we talk in twenty
minutes we're talking 30 or 40 minute
lost work that the other guy got the
rebel duration total duration of the
actual you know amrap you know whatever
they're doing right they never just run
on cross cameras as many rounds or reps
as possible and then you know you start
talking about in the skill work right
what is the theme for the month we
trying to develop someone's handstand we
try to there's a lot of things in place
it's a it's a challenging topic to
discuss briefly but in theory it's hey
let's have a let's have some big macro
goal right maybe it's to get everybody
ready for a five kids coming up maybe
it's to get the skill of maybe we start
noticing that our gym members need
benefit in X let's create that macro
goal and then during our warm-ups make
sure we touch base on it several times a
week
Dennis have these other goals where it's
like we go heavy two three times a week
right then we go longer met cons or
metabolic conditioning workouts couple
times a week and we add any short burst
high-intensity ones a couple times a
week so in skeleton you won't think
about you want to push you on a pull you
want to squat once a week right you want
to incorporate the Olympic list as you
know when you can and that's connect the
big picture stuff but you also when you
program you want to think about kind of
this idea of you know if I'm programming
a workout I want to think about what's
going to keep people moving so you
wouldn't want to do for example squats
lunges
jumping air squats jumping lunges and
what it was like a bunch of whatever so
will end up happening is people will
just burn out their legs let us sit
there and stand there until they can
recover but now if you did you know
jumping lunges followed by push-ups
they're not the same muscles right
they're different functions and so you
can keep your body moving and as you
mentioned when we were chatting before
recording just the audio the Olympic
lifts generally would come after say a
May familiarity at least a familiarity
maybe a mastery of mechanics of say
powerlifting movements and some
gymnastic components well I think we
incorporate the Olympic lifts early on
we do how do you do that safely I think
it ultimately just comes down to the
coaches that are doing it right how do
you you start off you make sure that
people can do it right with just the PVC
pipe or a light bar and then you can
work your way up but I think the
difference is that whereas with the
powerless it doesn't take as long to
developed all the techniques
incorporated with it what the Olympic
lifts it does and so you need to be okay
with doing the Olympic lifts early on
right almost from the beginning it's
okay but you need to do them at a
moderate controlled level versus the
back so you can kind of push a little
bit more I mean you could push them all
but you don't want to push the Olympic
lifts so much so these are developing
bad habits and the same thing applies
the backslash is a little bit less
technical so the Olympic looks a little
bit easier to in court you know they're
highly technical sure let's just say you
have average person off the street or
power lifter comes in I want to learn
Olympic weightlifting if they have
really bad thoracic mobility and
shoulder extension right so they're
they're here right they can barely get
there their biceps past there their ears
give any any favorite approaches to
helping address that or any suggestion
you know our friend Kelly has some good
tools the mobility WOD start yeah yeah
Kelly's threat I mean I think that
there's multiple different things you
could do but ultimately need to commit
to it right I mean if you have poor you
know shoulder range of motion it's going
to take you a while to develop that and
you know that doesn't mean you have to
avoid all this altogether still doing
just recognize you need to put in the
time you know a couple you know 10 20
minutes a day to develop the range of
motion and mobility and the best way to
do that is by incorporating the
movements slow in control with light too
little no no wait
right if you want to really develop a
good squat try and work on the squad up
against the wall with no weight and work
through the full range of motion of it
up against all you mean to face and roll
yeah
question from Luke Campbell asked about
his training the former endurance
athlete now coach Chris Henshaw it was
interesting to hear how a giant like
Jason could build his aerobic capacity
without sacrificing size or strength how
does he do it specifically that's a
great question
you know Hinshaw is great you know years
ago I started looking at summary results
from across the game it would be like
you know top 10 top 10 top 10 top 10
50th you know top 10 top 10
idec oh boy I got a glaring weakness
there and so I found Chris he really
helped me out he made running fun for me
he made running who is who is Chris just
for the close you know I eat a local guy
right here out of Pensacola Bay Area
yeah and he's a former you know Ironman
triathlete really successful but he but
he has a unique way of making running
quantifiable and fun and what I mean by
that is you know go to the track and
before just make a run 400 meters I
would just like running aimlessly but
it's so good for him to give me you know
100 meter pace goals 200 meter pace
goals etc and then those goals then
turning is something I could really try
and shoot for and I think going back to
the whole thing about someone going to
the gym is for those people who are
interested in doing running or doing to
us having a program that kind of gives
you quantifiable numbers issue 4 I
believe is a great way not only get
better results but also to keep them
more fun you know you just go out for a
5k on your own that's cool I get it but
you should start quantifying what your
target numbers are and your target paces
and that's what I did with him and
that's why I was able to maintain those
numbers when you were at your peak of
training what did your nutrition look
like and were there any go to
supplements on top of that it's a tricky
sort of murky waters that we get into
sometimes and it's fine if any of them
were sponsors but if you'd just indicate
which which were if that's the case but
diet so with your nutrition look like in
at the height of training and then any
particular supplements that were kind of
your go to so I never have and I until
this day eat as much as what most people
probably think I eat but with the amount
I was training sometimes you know just
broccoli and cauliflower weren't cutting
it for the carbohydrates I needed
everything so sweet potatoes had to be
thrown in and things like that I try to
eat real food right I still do I try to
eat real food and I try to avoid excess
amounts of sugar
different types of things that doesn't
mean that if my daughter wants to go out
and you know if it's her birthday I'm
not going to eat her birthday cake and
never has meant that right I'm okay with
that
I trained because at times I won't be
able to go in and enjoy a you know a
margarita with my wife right that's okay
and it always has been that same way
whether I've been training at the
highest level or where I'm at today and
you know as far as recovery
you know I partner with a company called
Pro genex I think they make a good
recovery tool for me that's something I
use outside of that maybe some fish oil
and that's pretty much the extent of it
right it's just real food I think people
don't realize the value you can get from
just consuming real regular foods and
did you track macros and all that type
of stuff
just now a lot of the guys the top don't
really track all the macros some of them
do but no not a lot of the guys you know
well I don't just work hard train hard
and just eat appropriately all right
this is this is a question I would love
to hear your thoughts and this is from
Lee Jackson what do you picture your
work out to be when you hit 60 years of
age that is I mean I think my workouts
gonna be roughly the way it is right now
just just basically scale down meaning
you know the the demands that I have at
you know my age with you know my
strength like we all need to [ __ ] we
all need a press on your left so when
I'm 60 30 50 I still want to be doing
those same movements I just might do a
little bit less intensity right and even
now being 31 the intensity I can bring
the workouts a little bit different when
I was 25 my body's been beat up a lot by
doing that and so I just need to
recognize it list my body recover as
well as I can but the amount of volume
I'm putting in isn't as much that used
to mean I assume that I'm 160 the amount
of volume I'm putting in wouldn't be as
much but the movements would be similar
is there any particular type of movement
conditioning strength fill-in-the-blank
that you'd really like to work on and
develop more now in other words you
talked about like top 10 top 10 top 10
50s plays top 10 top 10 are there any
particular weaknesses that you're trying
to work on now it doesn't have to be
limited to the gym either like is there
anything that you're there working on
currently I mean obviously you know I
like rolling jiu-jitsu there's how the
fingers get better at there but for
it's really on the business side on the
family side right I'm trying to be the
best dad I could be the best husband I
could be and I'm trying to support our
business and run it the best way
possible and treat people that way and
that's what I'm really focused on you
know stealing a line from our Cuban it's
just the sport of business and I'm
trying to win at that right now for
myself particular so that's why I'm
focusing on my fitness side I'm still
hitting it all the time right I still
work out really hard but on any specific
goals other than just to maintain my
fitness so this is this is actually a
segue they're going to talk about family
a little bit and these were very highly
uploaded so this is a question from
sherry gall I've so admired him as an
athlete and businessman his work ethic
and determination to continue to improve
as well as his humility have pushed him
to great levels of success I've also
watched his journey through Ava's
illness and seeing him give back in the
midst of it blood drives cetera I know
behind all this is a good marriage I'd
like him to talk about marriage and how
Ava is doing I would also be fun to hear
his perspective on the evolution of the
sport but let's let's keep that separate
can you talk a little bit just about the
components of a good marriage and also
just tell us a little bit about your
about your family and and Ava yeah a lot
of people listening are going to be
familiar sure yes so my wife and I
actually we started dating freshman year
of high school so 14 15 years old and
we've been together almost ever since
what happened is we started dating for a
week two weeks actually I thought we
were in love where I went home I told my
mom I'm like mom I found a woman I'm
going to marry right and I was all fired
up and then of course two weeks later
she dumped me because she said I was too
nice
well you know a year later right she
knew she knew you know we were meant to
be together so we end up getting back
together again a year later we haven't
been separated sense right so that was
you know 15 16 years old and so you know
went to college graduated college
together did our thing got married in
2009 had our first child in 2011 Ava and
we had our second child under 14 Caden
Ava was diagnosed with leukemia January
21st 2016 so about a little over a year
ago
and you know I think when you talk about
what makes a marriage successful I think
it's an obviously a number of things you
have to respect each other you have to
become best friends you need to be able
to be okay with you know supporting each
other on their journeys but you also
need to align well on difficult times
and I didn't know that until Ava got
sick you know when you're in high school
you don't know how your wife is going to
react or girlfriend's gonna react to a
negative situation in life I think
what's really intriguing about what
happened to us is my wife and I and my
family in general has got a lot closer
through Ava's diagnosis primarily
because she was so strong and she still
is
and that's immense really exciting for
me because I take on like hey you know
we're going to get after this we're
going to be successful and she was the
one who really started that from the
beginning you know when we we first
found out Ava had leukemia
we we were called the ER at Stanford ER
before that she was on a lot of leg pain
and different types of things it was
when did that start how old was she so
she should right now she's five
she'll be six and a month you know it's
look looking back on it now it probably
we probably could have identified the
Chevy Kimia earlier but everything like
had a reason like sure she had an ear
infection they shed another one they
shed another one and then you know
doctors like it's the worst year
infection I've ever seen her like Wow
well her immune system seems kind of
suppressed like we didn't really think
about every cycle we'll just keep you in
our medicine she's an ear infection and
it's like oh my legs really hurt I can't
walk more than a hundred feet without
stopping oh man must be growing pains
let's get you a trampoline let's get you
into PT all these different things then
she started having bruising and that's
where we knew something was up and so
waiting for blood work we called in the
ER and when they told us that night that
she had leukemia he was at like 2:00
a.m. in the morning and I just remember
you know it was it was a very
challenging time for us and now I've had
a lot of time to reflect on it so I'm
little less you know you know I used to
talk about a lot harder now that I've
reflected on a lot it's a little bit
easier to talk about I just remember
when I told my wife you know she just we
went on you know we're you know I was
crying she just looks at me she's like
hey look you tell our family you know
tell our family let him know she has
leukemia but just tell them that they
want to cry they can crowd outside but
as soon as we walk in the doors they
better be happy
and they better have a smile on their
face or else they can't be lighting
right and it was kind of mentality that
was just like you know kinda like you
know she's just like yeah hell yeah
we're in a crush this [ __ ] and then it
made me realize like oh yeah we're gonna
crush it like it was just very much so
like football like you know you're in
the huddle and like you're in the fight
of your life and it's like no no we're
going to crush this thing right and
we've had them in tality ever since and
you know her strength has been is been
awesome to see from a marriage
perspective right says that's kind of a
cool cool thing to find out about your
spouse for sure what types of practices
or routines anything really do you have
that helps the family to be as cohesive
as possible well I think we have a lot
of really good family support so we've
been super blessed you know the night
that my daughter was diagnosed my mom
and dad took my son and took him for a
month we were in the hospital for five
weeks right Lucile Packard they've done
some really great things for us but you
know like when you see that family
around and then all of a sudden my
father-in-law would be there every day
my father would just be sitting in the
waiting room right we wouldn't call on
when doing you just you sit there and
that family dynamic has been something
that's been really special to see and
it's something that we'll never I'll
never forget and even now here we are
over a year later and we still have a
lot of challenging times and it's a
family that helps us get through all of
it right because my for example on
Saturday we were in Vegas my mom and dad
helped watch our children so my wife and
I could go have a night out to ourselves
and those are really important things in
life that my wife and I since the
beginning I've always said hey look it's
we love our children but it's me and you
first for our relationships our
relationship isn't good then we're not
going to have a stall at home for our
children and so we really try to set
aside time to do date nights and do this
that which has really been helpful
especially during this time because
sometimes we have to have adult
conversations like right after this I'm
going to go see a counselor because you
know we need to get some support to help
us with this situation and my wife had
to have adult conversation about that to
go see a counselor yeah yeah if you were
giving advice to someone who for
instance just found out their child is
diagnosed with X some type of very
intimidating disease and they wanted any
thoughts or advice from you whatsoever
like for instance what your wife said
which was
you can cry but has to be outside once
you come in yeah you have to have a
smile on your face is there is there
anything else that you would that you
would share with them I think it's
really important to educate yourself
right educate yourself on disease so my
daughter is a ll it's a specific type of
leukemia she that it's very treatable
which is awesome right there's a lot of
them that aren't as treatable and my
heart goes out to those families I mean
you come sit in the oncology department
for a day with me and you'll just be
humbled so what I would say to them is
educate yourself we've had phenomenal
healthcare phenomenal but there's been
one or two times where we've had to
catch the doctors because sometimes you
know they have other things going on but
for me there's no something else going
on it's just this but I need to be able
to educate myself on it with all the
different medications what's going on
here what is this what are the side
effects what should be looking for
because those things are critical
especially for us we end up in the ER
probably once every two weeks because of
temperatures but we have to be actively
engaged to take the temperature we have
to be actively engaged on what the side
effects are of certain medicines I think
that's the most critical pieces educate
yourself on what's going on because no
one's going to care more than you're
going to care this is going to seem
maybe like a gear shift but I think it
could be related when we were talking
about transfer when we're in the gym
earlier looking at say modeling your
push-up position so that it transfers to
other movements your elbows aren't
flaring out looking at deadlifting say
first and foremost a conventional stance
so that it transfers more to cleans
everything else
you mentioned AMRAP earlier as many
raptures many rounds as possible and you
mentioned AMRAP philosophy before I hit
record I was like okay I want to come
back to that so what is that what does
that mean does it apply to areas outside
of oh yeah Jim so it's actually
something I've been working on for a
while and I've given talks about it's
called the MRAP mentality and to me it's
the way that you know I kind of live my
life and I'm trying to live my life and
what the amorite mentality really means
is think about if someone said you hey I
want to do as many push as you can in a
minute while you're doing them you just
focus on that right not focus on
anything else just focus on the push-ups
and then when you're done with that you
move on right now on podcasts with you
I'm focused on them I'm am rapping with
you right now we're trying to do the
best we can together but what I'm not
doing is on my phone
right and talking to you and trying to
work at the same time right I'm not
doing that because you know I think
nowadays I would make the argument I
don't know if we're less productive or
more productive than we were 20 years
ago because 20 years ago when you're at
work you're working when you're at home
you're at home now it's just huge
carryover so what I found myself doing
for many years and I had to really knit
myself a button I still I'm trying to
get a lot better it is I wouldn't be
focused on my family or what focus on
what I was doing I be focus on our
things there's times where I go to
dinner and I would be having dinner with
my life and I wouldn't remember anything
we talked about so I'll be thinking
about the CrossFit competition I had
coming up right and that was an example
of me not am happy not being present and
focused on what I was doing so the
theory is you identify your focus right
whatever it may be you know for me it's
family fitness business then you work
hard at it right you whatever it may be
then you switch gears and you do this
throughout your day and then every now
and then you really ate so I'll give you
an example for a while
I was going competing at the highest
level in CrossFit running the business
and I had the family then I had more
children the business grew and the
competition got harder so I decided to
switch gears and go team because I
didn't have as much time to allocate to
these other things so I'd have switch
gears evaluate what was really important
to me and then do that but then when my
daughter got sick it was another time
for me to re-evaluate what am I trying
to really focus on and how many things
can I actually AMRAP so now I chose not
to compete because I want to do the best
I can in business then I want to switch
gears and go as I can with family and I
still want to work out but I can't spend
as much time on it and that's kind of a
my mentality is identify her focus work
hard at it and switch gears and every
now and then re-evaluate and get rid of
similar stuff on your plate and when
you're when you're revalue inning do you
sit down with a pad and a pen and write
it out do you have a set time when you
might do that in the morning or at night
like if you could just describe perhaps
some of the details of what that looks
like
I mean reevaluating happens with big
moments in your life such as your
daughter getting sick or your getting
married or you have children you have
reevaluate with the things you're going
on you used to love maybe playing video
games for three hours a day once you
have a kidney reevaluate you
do anymore right you just can't it you
need to reevaluate those times and so
reevaluation happens kind of internally
for me whether I'm you know on the bike
just kind of like you know thinking in
my thoughts or whatever it may be but I
identify every so often when I read I
wait but on a consistent daily basis I
try and check in on myself and try ask
myself hey does I do the best job today
as I could to be a father to be a
husband to be a business owner and did I
maintain my fitness did I do that today
and if the answer is yes [ __ ] hell yeah
but if the answer's no that there's
always tomorrow right and and I think if
you do those micro goals on a daily
basis it doesn't lead to these oh [ __ ]
moments where you wake up and you've
been doing the same thing for five years
and you're unhappy right you need to
start taking that in your own hands on a
daily basis and evaluating what are some
of your goals right now from a business
standpoint I mean I just think that
service based fitness is the way to go
I really do I feel very passionate about
it I think that use it what does that
mean just service like you walk into a
gym I want to be serviced once I want to
help me I want the guidance and
direction you know think about hotels
you go into a hotel gym the Four Seasons
everywhere else is like hello sir how
can I help you this that you're going to
gym there's no one there
use young elliptical and you have an
aimless workout no Direction no guidance
so from a business perspective I want to
bring service to the hotels I want to
bring service to corporate wellness
where instead of people is going to the
gym and you know wearing their
headphones now listen they're creating
connections and that helps with
productivity in the workplace it creates
with fostering a sense of more culture
in that workplace and then also wanted
on the you know commercial side open to
the public I want to be experts in the
best at service based fitness right
bringing the highest level of quality
coaching combined with quality
programming in a fun atmosphere that's
what we're really focused on I know this
then if we could rewind the clock this
is from Tyler Eggman I think it is if
you that means Jason could go back to
2008 after winning the CrossFit Games
what advice would you give yourself in
regards for training for the games
and/or business now what advice would
you give
yourself at that time doesn't have to be
actually related to cams business I'd
say hey what advice period the advice I
would say is earlier on identify this
whole concept behind my mentality and
evaluate more regularly because there's
times in my life that I that I regret
not spending quality time with you know
but I mean I don't necessarily regrets
his goddess where we're at today but
there's been times where I haven't been
the most present father I've been doing
a lot of rent things and I wish I'd
learned that earlier on at least now
when I travel or like the smile of the
house at 4:00 and I'm not going to be
home until later at least now every time
I do that I recognize that it's a
sacrifice I'm making but that I have to
accept it and then you know try and make
it right in the future right but at
least being aware that there's sacrifice
I think before was just kind of like I
was trying to just do so much now you
know identify and say no to more things
so I could really start pinpointing my
focus the question I had earlier about
how you go about doing that is still one
I'd like to dig into a little bit I
think it's so important for instance I
was chatting a few months ago with this
older gentle
and every quarter he gets a report card
from his wife and the report card is
zero to ten in four categories he's got
provider husband father lover those are
the four Wow and he for he owns his own
company at least one company and travels
a lot so let's say he's traveling but
it's for business purposes and he's
opening up new manufacturing plants or
whatever might be in China who knows so
he's gone so again you might get a 10
out of 10 and provider but he's going to
probably be very low on the lover score
and so on and so forth you know maybe
five out of six on the others who knows
and it's allowable as long as he has a
good average
so like one can drop as long as the
others are higher yeah and so on how do
you keep track of
reprioritizing or think about that is it
is it all in the head or do you put it
down anywhere or is it something that
you try to do at the end of each workday
and we talked about a little bit yeah I
think it's just in my head I think it's
just constant evaluation whether I'm you
know I like to let's just say you know
be alone my thoughts in like in the
garage working out and I just think
about you know hey what am i doing right
now what am i doing well look we do
better at how can I be better at this is
this assist and it's just that constant
pursuit of being better at whatever I'm
doing I think it's an internal
conversation myself and I think that if
I ever get complacent or comfortable
that's where I start getting nervous and
I think I want to get uncomfortable in
business I want to get uncomfortable and
get out there and start sharing my
message of what I'm trying to do and
what we're trying to accomplish and
provide for more people to do what they
love for a living and these are the
conversations I have my head right is a
ava's getting better now I can start
focusing a little bit more on this but
don't forget about this you know and
things like that do you have any
favorite books or books that you've
gifted to other people either or both
the one that stands out to me the most I
read a lot I think there's some really
poor books at the airport I really do
sure anyways for me I like more of a
Pratt's publication book I like a book
like Mark Cuban's sport of Business I
like it because it gets me fired up I
like it because it's a real story from a
real guy just saying like it is and it's
easy reading it's not so analytical and
things like that and so that's the book
I like got it let's talk about morning
rituals if you have any so this is from
da SG know our SGA excuse me what are
some morning rituals or reflections that
he does to keep passions alive while
juggling children and life's twists and
turns so I would say let's focus on the
on the routines or rituals I could give
any if we look at the first 90 minutes
of your day and I'm sure it varies but
generally speaking or there's certain
routines habits elements that you have
I'd say in general it's probably some
type of exercise in general there's
exceptions that right but in general
it's exercise we're going to be
jiu-jitsu or you know hitting it in my
garage whatever it is I like to get the
body moving and I like to get flowing
early in the morning do you do that
before breakfast after breakfast before
we're bright 50s that's before the kids
get up that's before my wife is up
that's before everything that what time
is that typically would you say um I
mean it varies you know used to be a lot
earlier and now it's like I mean well
this morning I left early yesterday I
left early but on average is probably
six six yeah some days is a lot earlier
some days is seven and you're exercising
on empty stomach yeah
did you drink coffee I do I love coffee
do you drink coffee before your workout
you save that for later how many cups of
coffee the other day I probably have one
and a half okay
very much baby I love coffee but what I
would do is throw me exercise come in
see the kids I'll make my coffee like
doing pour overs I want to get a really
cool espresso machine that's what I'm
working on next then they don't hang out
with the kids they get breakfast when
they go out to school and I go off to
work and we do our thing and then I'll
be there you know you don't go to
meetings or the different gins I'll try
and just see what's going on then
sometimes I'll do uh you know work out
I'll take one of our classes right
throughout the bay area and then I'm
always home for dinner at 5:30 with the
family and I get back on emails and
different stuff around 7:00 8:00 around
7:30 till about 10:00 when I keep
because the kids go to sleep so
basically I just regiment my day is like
it's exercise good the body moving it's
time with the family briefly in the
morning they go to school I go to work
then when I get home at 5:30 we have
dinner we hang out then for the rest of
night I'm doing work and I go to bed I
triangle a bed by 10:30 10:00 10:30 and
then do it all over again do you have
any particular and maybe this doesn't
happen me but when you you have so many
different hats or any of your business
owner father husband certainly
competitor may perhaps not going to the
games necessarily but still you have
extreme athletic drive do you have
insomnia or do you find it easy to sleep
do ever happens on here you said I find
it pretty easy asleep you know you think
with the different stresses I have I
know I think it's because I exhaust
myself throughout the day I generally
run at a high like some people say it's
like the full throttle or like you're
like I generally run on a high level
throughout the duration a day okay like
a kid yes
and all of a sudden I get to like like a
bedtime checkpoint yeah I know what
happens to me because he's before have a
sort of high standard RPM which is good
do you have any winddown routines or
anything you like to do before bed I
mean generally it's answering a lot of
emails because during the day I'm doing
a lot other substantial a lot of emails
getting back to people and then
sometimes my wife and I will watch a
show together but that's pretty much it
that's it and then they split in the
face planner and on the weekends I'm
like you know we like to travel out to
go do things like last weekend or this
weekend coming up with wind is LAN I put
my daughter and we can have to run in
Mexico to see one of our locations also
a good time so we try and travel as a
family and have those times who do you
go to for business advice and I got a
few I mean you know we have a few
mentors that really helped out some of
our our corporate partners Western
Digital is one of them so many
executives in there have really been
amazingly helpful just in asking about
things because for me in my industry
sometimes I get overwhelmed so I need to
get outside my industries are asking
what's going on and you know I have also
friends through different sponsorships
that I have that they've really helped
me out from you know Paul and I have a
lot of people and then in the beginning
you know nobody really like Paul Gomez
it's got Michael Donna
Jerry and then Joe jig and Tino back in
the day right he was like the original
guy that really kind of took me under
his wings from a business perspective
and then just got men taught me
everything to do with sales ok so wait
so is Jill the fellow on the elliptical
yep
Josie elliptical and men was a guy who
came over on a ship from Vietnam got in
a concentration camp and I want to say
like Korea or something and I'm getting
here selling perfume door-to-door and
now he's doing really well for himself
so straight up hustle how did you meet
men he was a Jim sale guy and I wanted
to be like him he was making big checks
so you met him at the same time that
here also later doing the elliptical
yeah mentoring sessions yes well I
happening now and watching him I was
working the front desk and so men would
put in his sales slips and I looked at
his Commission this list I was like dude
what's going on teach me how to sell and
he did and that was really a cool
experience because I learned how to talk
to different people identify what their
wants and needs were and you know see
what's going on but it was also time my
life
I start to recognize that you need to
run an ethical business just because you
make money making money is not
everything in life running a very
ethical successful business is critical
for me and what would happen is I would
sell them the dream like hey join our
gym $4.99 a month and you know you're in
the best shape your life but they
wouldn't and I knew I was selling on a
false hope and so that's when I got into
the kind of like the group coaching
style which just changed the game for me
I'm going to talk about two two pieces
of that what made been so good at
selling I mean the best way to describe
it is straight-up hustler I mean just
just hustler like right because I would
but for some people that's going to
conjure the image like some guy was a
fold-out table and three-card Monte
who's like picks up and runs away from
the cops when the sirens are he lived by
the code you know ABCs always be closing
he would just identify what someone
needed to hear and he would work really
hard at doing it and there was no
sugarcoating he would follow up the
people he would tour people well he
showed me from an early age that there's
no easy answer in life you got to put in
the work and you got to get on the
phones and hustle it and you want to you
want to get leads go to the collections
who like all the members who are past
due call them all and try and collect it
go back to people who visit the gym from
five years ago and call them and I would
just end up with stacks be on the phone
better than that yeah maybe you get one
what's the so what would be an example
of say and a stingy successful script or
question when you're when you're calling
up the Glengarry leads that you have
from five years again yeah what what
what does a good call look like if
you're if you if someone in your company
had that job today and you're like
there's a stack better start smiling and
dialing what would you tell them I mean
I think you start off just saying hey
i'm you know i'm jason khalipa with NC
fit i just want to follow up your you
know whatever i think really what you
were trying to just identify hey so you
know you know how was your experience
we're just checking up did you enjoy
your experience what were you looking
for out of your experience and you
identify what they are looking for right
and say oh well did you hear that we
actually just added this program that
you know kind of tailors to what they
were looking for and i think finding out
what people are looking for i think is
really important instead of trying to
force-feed what you think they want find
out what they do want right
asking good questions yeah what's what's
one of the magic ingredients to a good
tour he said mentored well um and he
toured the best you know you know to
some people just be treadmills
ellipticals but to him it was it was
money-making pieces of machinery that
you could sell hey this is the you know
lifestyle 1032 top of its class
it comes the fan it seems music to right
and you just use Excel on a Mercedes you
know it's like and then you tell by the
treadmill you top of this that oh by the
way let me show you downstairs
did we you know and then finally get
down and it's like oh did we tell you
though that you could for an additional
eight dollars a month in you tell
service and let me show you those towels
go let me show you what they look like
let me show you the quality of them
right and those what type of things you
learn right as you did yeah but did he
have a strong accent or no oh yeah no
that's great though because it just
shows like it does not matter a very
strong do to be Howard no nobody powered
through it I used to live in San Jose
and I used to go to a Vietnamese barber
shop and it's it's one my best friends
grow that was Vietnamese in Long Island
and like when when anyone has a strong
accent it's a heart it's a strong accent
but he was able despite that to just
power through and become one of the top
it's not top oh he was a dude yeah oh
yeah he's a baller
learned a lot from him I all right I'm
going to ask just a few more questions
and then we get around to sometimes
since we're basically in the same same
neighborhood uh one would be if you
could put any message on a billboard and
this is a metaphor really but just to
get a message out to millions of people
on so let's assume it's non-commercial
read so it can't be an advertisement but
what let you put on a billboard I mean I
would I would love to get this out to as
many people as you could possibly push
this to it would just say like it's be
easy if like life is good and I mean
that because I really believe that
meaning when you seem children you know
when you've seen children on ecology
your whole perspective yes--she I was on
the road this woman is just tailing me
so hard
coming around get all crazy I look over
at her I'm just like easy like easy like
life is good you have a beautiful car
you look healthy and young and pretty
whatever like chill the hell out you
know and I think people they get so
caught up in these little problems and
he let it manifest in something so great
to be stopped - they never stop to
reflect that hey look life is okay but I
choose to look at the world
me personally I choose look in the world
in a pair of glasses not sunglass I
choose to look at things in a brighter
light because especially after yeah I
spent three nights in the ICU and I my
daughter was on the brink of not good
you know you don't go to the ICU as a
cancer patient I mean was really really
not good
right there's only time that we really
felt like it was a life in that
situation I'm sitting there and there's
a baby to my left and he's 7 months old
and his dad comes in the baby had never
left the ICU before and all night they
were they were sucking fluid out of his
kids lung because he had pneumonia or
whatever it was and I'm sitting there
for two days straight right up all night
eating muffins looking at my daughter
over here like really not in good shape
and this guy this baby over here in the
dead and I'm just somatic and people are
complaining that there's traffic and
[ __ ] and it's just no I'm not
expecting people I never want anybody to
be in our position I don't but what I
want going to do is really reflect on
their life and realize that everybody
has something to be grateful for if you
think about it right you're alive you're
well you have the ability to get up and
go do some amazing things you know and I
think that sometimes you'll get caught
up they forget that I could they could
use a reminder of that yeah I think that
is where she we should wrap up that is I
think that is if among many other things
what I want people to remember so that's
that's a fantastic point and just in
closing where can people find you online
learn more about you learn more about
your business and and and anything else
you'd like them to take a look at yeah I
mean I
nc fit right ansiedad fit would be great
I'm very active on Instagram jason
khalipa
I don't use Facebook as much as I should
and Twitter and I believe H K H al IPA
and you know I do these things called
blocks of business there's seminars we
do for affiliate owners or gym owners My
partner and I JP we do them all for
charity and pediatric cancer and so you
know back to one of the questions we
have a blood drive coming up in
September we do that on a nationwide
scale at different CrossFit gyms around
the world just a place that since people
won't be listening I've hear smells it's
2017 yeah okay we're going to do an idea
yearly base oh you are okay yeah but at
the end of the day yeah you could just
find me and feed on fit jason khalipa
calm or Jason keybinding scream you find
a lot of stuff about about me on that
awesome well guys say hello to Jason and
it's great to me man it's been a long
time coming I mean I've followed your
career for a while now so it's it's
really nice to meet in person and thanks
mark Bell mr. smelly himself mr.
thousand-pound back squat for making the
introduction and so first and foremost I
should say thank you for taking the time
I appreciate you making and making the
time today oh thank you yeah man really
fun and there's so much more to dig into
so hopefully folks will do around 2 and
get more questions answered and if you
want to see some additional video make
sure you go to Tim Doug forward slash
podcasts where you can find show notes
for this episode links to everything
books and so I mentioned links to Jason
his sites and so on as well as some
demos and work in the gym that we
recorded earlier so you can find that
conduct log forward slash podcast and as
always and until next time thank you for
listening
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and 500 Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I found
or that I've been pondering over the
week that could include favorite new
albums that have discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
red and that I've shared with my close
friends for instance and it's very short
it's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend so
if you want to receive that check it out
just go to 4-hour workweek dot-com
that's 4-hour workweek com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you
will get the very next one and if you
sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
LegalZoom I have used legals in myself
for many of my businesses and many of
the icons on this podcast have actually
used legals for instance Matt Mullenweg
of WordPress Fame CEO of automatic which
is now worth more than a billion dollars
first incorporated his company on
LegalZoom LegalZoom is a reliable
resource that more than a million people
have already trusted to help with their
businesses whether that's setting up a
will doing a proper trademark search
forming an LLC setting up a non-profit
or finding simple cease and desist
letter templates man do I use a lot of
those LegalZoom is not a law firm but
they do have a network of independent
attorneys available in most states they
can give you advice from the best way to
get started provide contract reviews and
otherwise help you run your business and
important there are no surprises
LegalZoom provides complete transparency
that means upfront pricing customer
reviews and a satisfaction guarantee
checkout legalzoom.com today to see how
they can make life better and easier for
you in your business if you're
pretending to be a lawyer on the
internet then you are asking for trouble
put together the safety nets get your
t's crossed and your eyes dotted enter
promo code tim t IM at legalzoom.com to
save 15% that's t IM for 15% off check
it out
legalzoom.com this episode is brought to
you by ink he'll use them personally
ever since I wrote the 4-hour workweek
I've been asked over and over again how
I choose to delegate tasks how I do
80/20 analysis and so on at the root of
many of those decisions is a simple
question actually two questions number
one how can I invest money to improve my
quality of life I use that an investor
as well ii how can i spend a little
money or moderate money to save
significant cut intel is one of those
investments they're a turnkey solution
for all of your imaginable customer care
needs I used I fell during the launch of
the 4-hour body which was very very
involved and they provided 24/7 customer
service for my land rush campaign
because it was critical for me to take
care of every person who purchased my
books and participating this allows me
to focus on the things that I am better
at my strengths like a marketing plan
that we've worked on for six months
implementing that until trains their
experience customer service reps to know
your business and your products inside
and out and make your customers raving
expands they answer more than a million
customer service requests every year and
they can do so across all platforms
including email phone social media text
and chat leaving your customers with
poor service or just leave Yoker service
which by the way in a competitive pool
is a huge liability long wait times or
unanswered messages carries a massive
cost and risk to your business Intel
removes the logistics and headaches of
this type of communication allowing you
to focus on your strengths and grow your
business it can be a real competitive
advantage and I see many many e-commerce
companies and tech companies thinking of
customer service and a good enough check
box or an afterthought and just like
Airbnb use design and innovative ways to
be a competitor and to win that you can
do the same thing with customer service
so as a listener of this podcast you can
get up to ten thousand dollars off the
discount
ten thousand dollars off your startup
fees and costs by visiting in telecom
forward slash ten so check it out for
more info go to ink Elcom i NK q PL comm
forward slash tip
[Applause]